good morning
my name is padma and i'm a consultant
pathologist at the subang jaya medical
center
subang jaya malaysia now lung cancer is
one of the most common cancers in
malaysia and it accounts for
roughly about 10 percent of all
malignancies
it is the most common cancer related
it is among the most common cause of
cancer-related deaths
and nearly 90 percent of our patients
present late either in stage three or
stage four
now the way we think about lung cancer
has changed and
we now know that lung cancer is not one
disease but multiple diseases
comprising of several molecular
subgroups
each of them distinguished by unique
driver mutations
and these driver mutations are
critically important
as available targeted therapies can
achieve
significant sometimes even dramatic
responses
and prolonged disease control
today i would like to share with you our
experience in molecular testing of
non-small cell lung cancer and how we
transitioned
from single to multi-gene testing for
non-small cell lung cancer
in our center this next slide
uh highlights where we work where i work
uh it's a drone view of the subungia
medical center which is a 393 bed
tertiary care hospital
located just outside kuala lumpur
to start off i thought i would discuss
briefly the current practice
in the management of advanced and
metastatic non-small cell lung cancer in
malaysia now testing for driving
mutations up to now
in our center has always been done in a
serial and
stepwise manner in part because of the
high egfr mutation rate in our
population egfr mutation negative tumors
are then subsequently tested for other
potential drivers such as
l cross b raf and so on
now things have changed because there
has been
a rapid development in the discovery of
new biomarkers
and we are also faced with the
challenges of having to provide
this critical information from
exceedingly small biopsies
because many of our patients either have
only psychological samples for analysis
or small core biopsies
where lung resections are very rare in
our environment
there's also a need to dramatically
improve turnaround times
so when we are settled with this problem
of trying to give maximum information
about the availability of
multiple driver mutations and having to
work with very small samples
it sort of forced us to rethink the way
we do our business
and how we actually manage our workflow
so the move towards multi-gene testing
was also accelerated
by the fact that we formulated and
published our own malaysian molecular
testing
consensus guidelines these guidelines
then serve as a backdrop in a useful
roadmap
evolving for evolving our strategies for
multi-gene testing
so with our with the help of our
diagnostic and former partners
the nexus initiative was conceived to
explore the best way forward
and today i want to share with you the
lessons learned
from this initiative
now this slide shows the heterogeneity
of egfr positivity
among different populations and it
highlights a comparatively higher rate
of egfr mutation possibility in asian
populations
in one of the earlier publications the
incidence of egfr mutation from
non-small cell lung cancer
back in 2012 demonstrated the higher
prevalence
of egfr mutation in the asian population
and this uh stretching from south to
north asia
the figures varied from 40 to 60 but
there was a clear distinction between
nation and western populations
the data also showed a slightly higher
risk
in female patients who are non-smokers
our own published data shows an egfr
positivity rate of about 39.5
in the malaysian population
this next slide highlights that over the
last 10 years or so with advances in
molecular genetics
we are able to profile the genetic
makeup of non-small cell lung cancer
patients
the figure on the left is a slightly uh
outdated genetic profile of about
200 adenocarcinoma
patient per study conducted in korea
and in the road on the right side of
this
slide is a simple roadmap of the kind of
advances that we've made in the
treatment of non-small cell lung cancer
from as early as 2004 with the
identification of egfr sensitizing
mutations in lung adenocarcinoma
and the way we have been using targeted
therapy
to manage these patients has
helped improve the quality of life
and in some instances prolonged
the the survival of these patients over
time
the development of health sensitive
tyrosine kinase inhibitors
and today the progress has reached that
point when we have third generation
tyrosine kinase inhibitors available for
elk and
in the recent years there's also been a
serious
series of immuno oncology treatment
options which
have been approved so the landscape is
changing quickly and it was
there was an urgent need for us to keep
abreast uh to do the correct things
and to help benefit the patients in the
best way possible
this next slide highlights a growing
list of targetable therapies
and it has provided the declination with
an arsenal of treatment options
with marked improved overall survival
which was
shared recently in you know called
an annual oncology meeting
so we have adenocarcinomas on the left
side and
squamous cell carcinomas on the right
hand side
and in the purple column
we have driver mutations and there are
targets and
targeted therapies and with potential
tyrosine kinase inhibitors
which may be deployed for these various
genetic aberrations we also have
below that a pink column
which highlights treatments and
therapies available
for patients who develop resistance
and these are therapies available in the
second line
so also listed right at the bottom of
the page
emerging biomarkers and these include
math rat
her2 mutations and also tumor mutational
burdens
recent meetings have also flagged out
some novel markers and treatment options
including
the detection of energy one fusion for
the use of a platinum
egfr x120 insertions and these have
always been a problem because
they tend to confer relative resistance
to pkis
and the egfr x120 insertions are
fairly common in fact the third most
common alteration in egfr
and of course there's been heightened
activity uh on the use of drugs which
which target kira's mutations and this
has
been a target that has eluded us for
some time
this next slide sort of summarizes the
kind of therapies that are
available the emerging new therapies for
non-small cell lung cancer
is your partner in session 20 mutations
rep fusion mutations
met exon skipping mutations ntrk
raw 32 keras b12c mutations
either accompanied with lkb1 mutations
or keras mutations alone
so the problem
of the small biopsies continues to
douglas
and these are this is a statement from
the islc
and some recommendations on the use of
liquid biopsy
for advanced non-small cell lung cancer
tissue is
still remains a gold standard and where
available
tissue is analyzed preferably using
a multi-gene panel with pdl-1 testing
thrown in as well should
drive a not be detected
and there is now a very powerful
argument to be made for using liquid
biopsies
again these are
can be tested using deep sequencing
next generation sequencing with the
caveat that
if one is not able to draw uh to detect
the driver mutation with liquid biopsies
then the correct thing to do would be to
reflect uh to
tissue biopsies and this algorithm
summarizes the approach that we've been
developing so
these are the molecular testing
guidelines
for malaysia and these consensus
guidelines
were developed with
experts pathologists
oncologists respiratory physicians
and it represents a consensus or
agreement among
experts with regard to how we may
approach
the diagnosis and the treatment
of a disease in this particular instance
non-small cell lung cancer and applying
this kind of evidence to clinical
practice
is we believe a requirement for best
patient care
it's an integral part of evidence-based
medicine not only
in individual and institutional clinical
practices
but also is
interesting for governments and peers
to want to know so
the summary of the findings
are listed on the lower left
lower right i'm sorry so the key
biomarkers that the vgfr mutation alkyne
rotary arrangements
are considered standard of care and
demolition guidelines and these are
tested
and where possible multi-gene sequencing
panels are preferred over single gene
testing
and we always need to be alive to the
fact that the quality of the test is a
key consideration
and we the guidelines insist on robust
in-house
validation as well as external
accreditation
uh you using external q a programs
so when we decided uh
that we were going to proceed with
multi-gene testing in our center
for first line nsclc a number of
issues had to be considered
these were in fact obstacles that needed
to be cleared before implementation
could be
could be done so deciding on an
actionable
target list and we based our
our choices on nccn guidelines and local
guidelines
and we decided that a small actionable
panel
could be developed for this use and we
also
included in that list other markers
which we felt
were evolving biomarkers or potential
biomarkers we included these in the
panel because we wanted to ensure the
longevity of this targeted panel
affordability was important and
the number of health economic studies
have been conducted
particularly in the us
and uh with regard to multi-gene testing
and its uh cost effectiveness
and it is important to note that the
affordability of this ngs panel that we
evolved
uh you know was actually very
collectible with
practitioners in the local environment
and this is something that
we were we were very cognizant of
because practices will vary across
geographical environments
and we need to factor in logistic costs
country gdp
local testing financial models
capabilities
local testing environment considerations
and so on
so the consensus was also important we
had to get consensus between healthcare
institutes
and professionals to drive this
initiative
and we are very thankful to pharma and
diagnostic companies
which were heavily involved in the
development and the education
of the of the clinicians and the
healthcare providers
which allowed us to to initiate this
program successfully
and of course the relevance and
of the availability of
treatment options both in the private
and public
sector were important considerations so
accessibility to the appropriate black
source
fundamental to the follow-up actions for
the panel testing
so the next study was initiated as a
single center prospective study
and we recruited 300 patients
we wanted to identify the incidence of
key actionable mutations
we wanted to map out potential
prognostic trends
which are unique to asian genomics and
it also provided
an important learning opportunity
to assess the possibility of
implementing nvs multi-gene testing
as a routine and
we disseminated a lot of this
information with the
help of pharma and diagnostic companies
through
cmes and
then we took off the panel that we we
devised was a limited 22 gene panel
and most of the key biomarkers were
included
this is a panel that i put up for your
configuration
uh there are some markers that are
missing
uh exon 14 skipping mutations and
cement amplifications are not part of
the panel
and these were addressed in a new ngs
panel that we are
developing so those
exon skipping and cement amplification
were tested as
separate uh stand-alone tests
outside of the 22 gene panel
so in our newer ngs panel more targeted
targetable genes have been included with
consideration of other major cancers
so that it would be like a catch-all
panel for colon cancers gastric and
breast cancers
the fusion gene panel will be expanded
to include things like energy one
and track two and three because the
current panel only
includes n-track one
so we we have up till the present time
uh only curated about 26 cases and
we have learned a number of things and
i'll share some of these experiences
with you
uh this is a breakdown of the list of
mutations that we
were able to get from these 26 cases
that we were able to
curate and uh we at this at the time
that this study was
that this data was collected we were
only three months into the study and
i admit that the data is limited uh
we uh profile 55 cases uh
with 26 year data points that were
curated
and in this interesting uh to note the
discordances that we already picked up
as a result of analyzing these tumors
using next generation sequencing and i
want to present here two cases
the first case 017 which is
a lung cancer case which was negative
for egfr mutation
on routine qpcr
and there were there was a low allelic
effect
uh fragmented uh on uh detected no sorry
relatively low allele frequency uh
detected
uh on ngs and so
we escalated it to digital pcr
where again we consistently detected
the mutation and therefore we believe
that this is real
for case 26 we had a stage for
lung adrenal carcinoma in a young
patient
and we detected an egfr x120 insertion
and this was missed on the qcr panel
because that panel did not include this
particular variant
and given the daily frequency detected
in ngs was higher
44 we actually explored confirming this
insertion
it is interesting to also note that in
session 20 as i mentioned earlier is the
third most prevalent idea for genomic
alteration
uh in asian genomics and the present
uh uh spectrum of egfr tki
uh therapies has poor efficacy against
uh in session 20.
um so um most of the
first second and third generation pks i
have not
shown to have much benefit but as i
mentioned in a much earlier slide
the combination of perhaps cetuximab and
a fatty name and a potential candidate
are just
possibly looks uh promising
so this next slide shows the presence of
concomitant mutation so we have egfr in
combination with p53 or sdk11
and this is interesting because this is
data that we would not have
otherwise otherwise been able to derive
had we only uh limited ourselves
to a
qpcr so
sdk11 and t6p53 have been reported to
have prognostic
significance we also detected p3ca
mutations
and there are contradicting reports as
to its prognostic value
for sdk 11 it
appears that mutations in exon 1 and 2
are associated with a shorter survival
and as far as uh the tpe 53 mutations
are concerned
uh there are many studies at the moment
to show that
both progression-free survival and
overall survival
in patients who are easier for mutated
but with the concomitant pp53
mutation uh fair worse
so these are these are interesting
observations and we are only now
beginning to
appreciate the significance of
what kind of impact they may have on the
therapies
that are being instituted for these
patients
so i want to stop here and just leave
you with some take-home messages
it's clear to us that from the nexus
initiative and some of the things that
we've learned
that that this is probably the way
to go the discovery of new druggable
mutations and evolving guidelines
and explosive growth really of
biomarker discovery and also
pursue the the availability of targeted
therapies
um has hastened the migration to
multi-gene testing given the challenges
that we face
with uh small baths having to work with
small biopsies and extract as much
information as possible from them
and in our own experience the use of a
limited 22 gene panel
while it does not include uh things like
exon skipping net excellent skipping and
net amplification
we still find that it's cost effective
uh
and it has allowed us to to uh
to deploy this kind of diagnostic
solutions locally rather than have
samples
and overseas we have
through the partnership with pharma and
diagnostics
made it affordable the turnaround time
is acceptable to most of our oncologists
and this has to some extent remove some
of the barriers
to the adoption of multi-panel testing
interestingly also the presence of
concomitant
molecular aberrations have given us
food for thought and for reflection and
we need to
of course correlate with clinical and
pathological
data and build a paradoxic approach to
how
all of this information the clinical the
pathological and the molecular may be
integrated
to provide a holistic picture of how we
should manage these patients
and lastly uh it has provided a very
unique learning experience
uh and i am confident that at least in
the malaysian environment
uh this will have far reaching
implications as to how we are going to
manage non-small cell lung cancer
and i will leave you with a final image
of my center
again taken over the drone a nighttime
picture
of the subundra medical center thank you
very much
you